bienvenue dans le monde du silence
ondulé tel un poisson le rêve de
beaucoup le quotidien des apnéistes
alors la fumée je crois que j'ai
découvert comme un peu tout les gens à
peu près dans ma tranche d'âge par le
bronze
il est magnifique l'image du grand bleu
partout des dauphins le camp tombe
amoureux xavier delpy a découvert la
plaie il y a deux ans et demi un peu par
hasard lors d'une sortie dans la mer
rouge avec les dauphins
depuis ce chirurgien de 35 ans passe son
temps libre sous l'eau
capable de nager sur 200 m sans respirer
xavier a connu une progression
fulgurante champion de france il ya
quelques mois le futur élan courtois
fait ces dernières ont dû la scion dans
la fosse de conflans sainte honorine
avancé second championnat d'europe sous
l'eau le nageur de saint-quentin connaît
deux phases la partie plaisir lors de la
cne statique une sensation d'apesanteur
reposante ce moment où les minutes
souvent trop courtes dans la vie
deviennent alors si long
mais aussi le côté mental ou l'apnéiste
doit se battre contre son corps et gaza
devient partout qui commence qu'est ce
qu'on appelle la phase de lutte ou là le
corps a envie de respirer et là c'est
complètement l'inversé le mental qui
doit distraire tu dois faire penser à
autre chose qui doit prendre le pas sur
le corps qui a envie de respirer
il est trés dans la tête mais bon il ya
quand même des problèmes de physiologie
parce qu'il ya un problème de
circulation d'oxygène rose dans le corps
et il ya des gens qui sont
physiologiquement c'est le cas de xavier
physiologiquement différents donc qui
ont une faculté de mieux gérer et
l'oxygène qu'ils ont l'homme poisson ne
se fixe pas de limites et combien monter
sur le podium des prochains championnats
d'europe à antalya en turquie